[Musik]
Netanya Küstenstadt nördlich von Tel
Aviv 230.000 Einwohner und eine Hochburg
der rechtskonservativen lecut-partei von
Regierungschef netter Jahr die äußerst
umstrittene Justizreform ist ein Thema
vor allem aber stören sich viele an dem
Protesten gegen die Regierung das ist
doch nicht das Ende der Demokratie wenn
jemand anderes Richter bestimmt ist das
das Ende der Demokratie wir hatten
demokratische Wahlen und jetzt sollen
die auch Richter Enden dürfen
konservativ sind hier viele aber nicht
alle einer Meinung
es kann nicht sein dass die Knesset über
dem Gericht steht das ist finde ich
antidemokratisch
[Musik]
klar
schlecht über Bibi redet der sollte fünf
Jahre in den Knast
[Musik]
wo gibt es das so schlecht über den
Regierungschef zu reden
an Unterstützern mangelt ist netanjau
nicht der Mann der seit 35 Jahren die
israelische Politik mitbestimmt zum
sechsten Mal die Regierung führt er hat
das Land immer weiter nach rechts
geführt Israels Besatzung des
Westjordanlands zum Normalfall erklärt
sein stramm populistischer Rechtskurs
wurde nur ab und zu noch vom Obersten
Gerichtshof gebremst auch deshalb so
glaubt der linke Soziologe und
Historiker Moschee Zuckermann soll das
Gericht jetzt an die Kette gelegt werden
jaow werde von vielen als Heilsbringer
gerade zu verehrt die Leute sind einfach
geblendet von diesem Mann der natürlich
Charisma hat und der natürlich ihnen
immer wieder
den bauchinselt
nicht den bauchpinselt und der vor allem
eine ganze Menge wirklich also teilweise
auch rentenpolitikerin aus dem
orientalischen Bereich dass er seine
urteilchen Bereich der Karriere
geschaffen hatte dass ihr Idol ne Tanja
wegen Korruptionsverdacht vor Gericht
steht und daher auch ein handfestes
Eigeninteresse an einer Kontrolle der
Justiz hat halten nicht wenige hier für
reine Propaganda der Opposition
die Medien Zeitungen und Fernsehen
bauschen das doch alles nur auf es ist
nicht so wie die behaupten ja da wird
jetzt demonstriert aber besser wäre es
die Regierung zu unterstützen die sind
ja gerade mal zwei Monate dran positive
Veränderungen brauchen mehr Zeit
hunderttausende wütende Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sehen in dem Plänen der Regierung
aber keine positiven Veränderungen
sondern nichts weniger als einen
Staatsstreich durch die Hintertür das
Oberste Gericht sollent machtet werden
die Regierung und ihre
Parlamentsmehrheit die Möglichkeit
erhalten Gerichtsurteile zu kippen und
künftig Richter selbst zu bestimmen ich
bin 27 Jahre alt und möchte dass meine
Kinder in einem demokratischen
Rechtsstaat aufwachsen ich will hier
Zukunft haben ohne Demokratie keine
Zukunft
sie wollen ein Regime der Mehrheit haben
und die Rechte der Minderheiten
abschaffen weder die Palästinenser noch
die Frauen und die schwulen werden dann
Rechte haben es wird ein Land in dem nur
noch die Mehrheit alles entscheidet
die Mehrheit das sind Netanya und seine
Koalitionspartner ultra religiöse
Parteien z.B die gerichtlich
sicherstellen wollen dass ihre Kinder
nicht zu Armee müssen dass der Staat
ihre Tora Schulen finanziert
rechtsradikale Zionisten die ins Gericht
wollen um den Siedlungsbau im besetzten
lässt jordanland und gebremst
voranzutreiben was das für Palästinenser
unter Besatzung bedeutet haben die
Bewohner im dorfuara südlich von na bloß
gerade hautnah erlebt
es waren fast 400 Siedler sie kamen mit
Polizei Armee Grenzpolizei sie griffen
alles an warfen Steine zündeten die
Autos an dann den Laden eine Frau die in
Panik aus ihrem Haus rannte wurde
beschossen
das war vor zwei Wochen ein jüdischer
Siedler Mob tobte sich unbehelligt von
Polizei und Armee in Hua aus Racheakt
für einen tödlichen Anschlag auf zwei
jüdische Siedler kurz vorher
die 70-Jährige naval verschanzte sich an
diesem Abend im Schlafzimmer im ersten
Stock ihres Hauses sie hörte wie die
Angreifer die Fassade des Hauses
anzündeten hoffte vergeblich auf Hilfe
ich hatte Angst um meine Töchter niemand
hat geholfen wir hatten alle Todesangst
sie haben geschrien es war schrecklich
warum so fragten aber lässt die
Regierung so etwas zu wir sind
unbescholtene Bürger aber ohne jeden
Schutz Feuerwehr und Zivilschutz aus na
bloß waren am israelischen Militärposten
aufgehalten worden die Bewohner
weitgehend sich selbst überlassen die
Bilanz in hora ein toter viele Verletzte
dutzende zerstörte Existenzen
das ist sicher nur der Anfang wenn wir
ihr Sicherheitsminister hat ja schon
angekündigt was auf uns zukommt es war
auch nicht der erste Angriff aber es
wird immer schlimmer
[Musik]
rechtsextremer Sicherheitsminister wegen
Anstiftung zu Rassismus und
terrorunterstützung rechtskräftig
verurteilt er will nach eigenen Angaben
nicht alle Araber vertreiben nur die die
nicht loyal sind
sein Amtskollege Finanzministers Modric
ein homophober Rassist der die
Überlegenheit der Juden propagiert
forderte huarachüsse ausradiert werden
ja hubbarer muss ausradiert werden aber
das soll die Armee übernehmen nicht die
Siedler
bei der Fangemeinde der radikalen
Siedler investorenland lösen diese Worte
Entzücken aus zwar ruderte der Minister
nach massiven internationalen Protest
etwas zurück er sei falsch verstanden
worden doch hier sehen Sie sich jetzt wo
ihre Leute die Regierung stellen dem
Ziel nah die landname militärisch
abgesichert massiv vorantreiben
die Regierung soll unsere Sicherheit
hier verstärken für die Siedler die hier
mitten in Israel leben und sie soll die
schnelle Erweiterung der Siedlungen ab
sichern
die Stimmung im Land ist aufgeheizt die
geplante Entmachtung des Obersten
Gerichtshofs polarisiert der Hass
zwischen Regierung und Opposition so
glaubt der Soziologe Zuckermann er nimmt
zu auch wenn die Koalitionsparteien ganz
unterschiedliche Ziele verfolgen einig
sind sie sich darin die Justiz unter
ihre Kontrolle bringen zu wollen genau
das wollen hunderttausende verhindern
israel soll ein demokratischer
Rechtsstaat bleiben die seit mehr als 50
Jahren andauernde Besatzungspolitik wird
dabei allerdings ausgeklammert das Thema
interessiert kaum noch jemanden wenn man
die Besatzung hinnimmt dann kann Israel
auch nicht in Anspruch nehmen Demokratie
zu sein und wenn Israel keine Demokratie
ist
dann ist sozusagen das was die Leute im
moment einfordern etwas das halt blind
ist
in der Tanja hoffen die Menschen auf
ruhigere Tage wohin das Land steuert
darauf haben sie keine Antwort
[Musik]